elysian de ce côté là personne ne s'y
attendait les abs que vous souvenez il
ya presque un an quand avait testé des
sites web du futur quand l'expérience -
comme je le rappelle ainsi qui regroupe
plein de sites web qui sont des
expériences voilà on teste des trucs
tout ça c'est un signe au banc ça c'est
cool bien sûr moi j'adore le futur
j'adore la science alors punique
trombone
c'est quoi ça
et on a trouvé comment at'on vouloir
voir j'ai trouvé ça cool mais j'ai envie
de pleurer en même temps c'est très
bizarre
opta le mec il a juste reproduit comme
si je te coupe est à tête en deux voiles
a envoyé le système boyata l'enquêté
contre aucun etc et tu peux toucher
chaque élément ce qui fait que ça change
le son comme causes bouchonnait on parle
comme ça pas pareil ouais je pense qu'un
truc à faire je pense qu'un artiste
devrait se servir de ce site pour faire
les le symbole d'une musique voilà alors
à j'avais vu ça google autodrome tu
commence à dessiner un truc et te
suggère quelque chose si par exemple je
veux faire un chat obs et ses oreilles
au parlement ils me trouvent des
arcs-en-ciel mon gars hop là c'est un
chat mais c'est un chapitre ces visages
d'un chat à voilà voilà c'est ça je
voulais faire c'est exactement ça que je
reste à un ours chaource et paraît que
changer quatre lettres et ça fait le
même mot voilà ça voilà voilà voilà
c'était le visage d'un nounours en fait
j'ai essayé de vous tromper pour que sa
troupe aussi le site excellence est
énorme si je fais une cafetière
voilà c'est ça une théière je voulais
faire bah oui bah je vous ai encore
trompé je vous ai des cafetiers en fait
c'est une th dessiner mais il a trouvé
google excellent très bien fait
excellent mais bon voilà moi je préfère
mes dessins je les trouve mieux sans
l'aide de ce truc donc bon riz bon
qu'est-ce que s'écrit bon en un sens
c'est un fond d'écran les couleurs et
tous ont généré à la devoir monter juste
à regarder et à te détendre c'est sympa
ça c'est sympa mais ça fait une bonne
vidéo de mer dans par contre ça là là
pour commenter ça va être chaud
et on observe la bande bleue qui part
sur la gauche bien sûr pendant que la
bande de violette passe elle derrière et
la bande jaune car timbres amendes lui
qui se multiplient aux quatre c'est
chiant c'est chiant mais pas mal ajustée
à l'air dingue
en gros tu fais une ligne et ils te
trouve une photo de la planète où tu
alignes est dedans quoi bon vous allez
voir par exemple je fais une ligne
droite et il me cale la ligne sur une
autoroute une image c'est génial mais
regarde c'est abusé je fais une ligne
comme ça il me trouve pile élite sur une
photo qui qui correspond non mes mecs
mais c'est génial de résister à une
meute rôle gerson de faire trop laid en
permanence et voit la roue du troll airs
du troll à la nanon la loi tepa ou fla
là t'es pas bien là acheter un peu brain
wolf c'est quoi ça ça a l'air très
étrange très étrange le début d'un
mauvais oeil times elle marchera pas des
terriens ce faux et voilà en fusion de
plantes
c'était génial expérience très court
très bien c'était un bon rapport qualité
tanger j'adorais alors on arrive sur un
site ok on va parler alice alice est une
femme qui devinent l'émotion de ce qu'on
va dessiner
pensez vous qu'elle va terminer
l'émotion de mes dessins elle nous dit
qu'il a l'air heureux à l'us savage mais
alice sec fait plaisir c'est que se
situe marche super bien c'est mais là si
je fais ça comme ça ok là il est
clairement vénère elle nous dit qu'il
est content mais nommée à lille et un
gris ça se boit boîte un showcase
il a l'air heureux encore nommé il est
cassé à lister kcr ça dégage n'importe
quoi alice elle nous a bouleversé la
sueur se distord il faut juste tordre
une boule si je comprends mais rob
d'arrondir et la matière cas dans les
boules dans les lampes pardon chauffante
là le truc qui monte et qui descend très
bien ce que je dis est ce que je fais à
queue avec maintenant mais c'est vrai
que là ça au mon dieu qu'est-ce qu'on
peut faire faire à ces genres à temps
mais ça c'est certain d'entre vous soit
en médecine là c'est de la balle oui à
mon pote regarde à quel point on est
dégueulasse on est formidable et
dégueulasse à la fois d'accord tu
choisis ce que tu fais apparaître ou
disparaître c'est malin là il ya
juste plus la peau là on retire le gras
là on retire la première couche de
mousse donc on voit les eaux et à la fin
il reste quoi moi ça va jusqu'au
nerf et oh génial ça poulet pour
découvert le corps humain donc tu sais
pas trop quoi faire tes journées ou
conteurs médecine
encore un truc avec les étoiles
j'aime tellement ça aide toi puisqu'il
revient bientôt d'ailleurs la de liesse
à la thomas pasquet donc sur terre rien
n'est si vous vous rendez pas compte à
quel point de cette petite merde je vous
montre quand même ça c'est notre soleil
d'accord lyall orbite de la terre et la
terre la ja venus et son orbite mercure
mars déjà mars par rapport à nous c'est
astronomiquement loin on peut y aller le
problème c'est revenir en vrai ça mais
si moi je crois si on veut y aller et
quand tu des zooms mon pote tu des zooms
aux potes
voilà voilà
voilà voilà tout ce qu'il ya en réalité
non mais parlons-en c'est
incroyable c'est le jour on pourra aller
aussi loin bon bah ouais enfin peut-être
qu'un jour les samoa des oies presse a
fait une grosse gueule de con pourquoi
j'ai une méga gueule de con c'est quoi
ce manque de respect là avait le respect
dans le futur il toujours pas là
apparemment ingérée macron je me sembla
macron je suis ton pire cauchemar
bâtisse et oui c'est bien moi tu ne
regardera plus jamais des vidéos de la
même manière makita excellent ce site là
j'ai vraiment adoré on peut jouer du
pied droit plusieurs alors là mais quoi
se régaler va faire des mélodies
exceptionnels attendaient des gens là
qui sont en train de jouer of tintin les
pires à temps et à béquilles georgie
bien
bon j'ai internet dès qu on partage un
truc qu'on est plein dessus ça fait
toujours un truc de merde comme sur les
sites où tu peux dessiner à plusieurs
sur un truc à chaque fois tout le monde
et si de n'importe quoi tout monde
gribouille sur des saints du voisin
pourquoi des profs et 800 tonnes
mordelles bons mètres a quand même dit
un mec qui fait super bien du piano et
au lieu d'en jouer à une gare pour faire
kiffer les gens il va sur ce site et il
est les gens saccagé son skill en piano
c'était salut toi bienvenue dans
pif mcces bolos en a marre d'aller dans
les concessions pour te faire agresser
par des vendeurs alors vas sur ce site
et masse des grosses caisses en hd mais
des jantes violette et une peinture
jaune car c'est la mode le jaune
l'eswc a envoûté par cette musique
triste qui te rappellent à chaque
seconde que tu n'auras jamais les thunes
pour l'acheter et heureusement parce
qu'elle est franchement dégueulasse
oh ça ça me plaît déjà ça me plaît je
sais pas ce qu'on va faire mais ça me
plaît énormément et je fais la sphère
cligner des yeux d'ailleurs super vite
elle joue au hockey
qu'est ce que je peux modifier d'autres
l'expression oh mon dieu
ces excellents sa lippe 5 au oui et
voici la preuve personne au monde qui
arriva à peser avec ses lèvres
je pensais que cette blague s'améliore
voilà elle est parfaite elle est
splendide apparent l'oeil quand tu
regardes tout à gauche qui devient pas
blanc si jamais rencontré avec le visage
atteint c'est bizarre je suis un peu
douloureux où il a l'air tellement vrai
bonjour pendant une seconde il y avait
l'air vrai en bref c'est un vrai mec qui
se fait scanner et là je suis en train
de le regarder dormir au chaud a été
vite en finir en prison un jour auquel
adam aimerait finir en beauté sur un
site génial
en gros c'est ainsi dans lequel choisi
une vidéo tirée d'un film muet hockey et
on faisait des films mais des fois ya
lille il ya du dialogue fin il n'y a pas
de dialogue mais il ya un panneau qui
apparaît avec marc est ce que le mag a
dit et là en gros mon micro va détecter
ce que je dis et il va le marquer dans
ce panneau là je vous montre
bougez pas je vais l'exploser ce petit
con mais elle m'a dit que nous exploser
il fermait de vin ce fils de je
vais exposer ses parrains ça n'a pas de
sens se sépare ainsi hollywood the end
d'accord bon ben voila c'était plutôt
j'ai un peu chocs ou tel truc je peux
vous votiez salut ça va
désolé je fermais de 20 mai est amer des
jeux permet de voir et à berne
bisous je permets de vous avec ta mère
je t'aime à tout à l'heure ça n'a pas de
fin et voilà incroyable c'était
mon premier court métrage i step aller
loin au cinéma a très vite les amis si
de la face de cette troisième vidéo et
dernière sur les sites web du futur en
fait ils en ont pas hésité palais mais
si elle vous a plus peur de rien fait
ils n'ont pas ajouté
tu as le mec est une prise de conscience
mon dieu j'ai oublié de la retire des
mais la vidéo ma carrière va se terminer
si je ne le dis pas
je suis un peu déçu parce qu'en fait il
y en a pas beaucoup de nouveau rêver on
était quand même passé à côté de sites
qui existait déjà à l'époque on a fait
nos deux autres vidéos et qu'on avait
pas vu et il était super comme ce tout
dernier par exemple je vous dis à tous
deux prochaines vidéos je remercie aussi
d'avoir regardé portez vous bien au
revoir
[Musique]